china cut off direct ties with taiwan
president tainwon's government after she
came into power in 2016 because thai's
democratic progressive party was founded
on the promise of independence and her
government seeks to deepen ties with the
us in fact thai's government's ties with
the u.s has improved much better these
years after several u.s officials came
to visit taiwan and bilateral ties are
increasingly improved which
probably aroused more anger from beijing
[Music]
china has increased its military
economic and diplomatic pressure on
taiwan a military front china regularly
sent its military aircraft into taiwan's
air defense identification zone which is
the buffer zone outside of taiwan's
airspace earlier this month china sent
150 military planes in five days into
taiwan's 80s while the u.s and its
allies held military exercises in nearby
waters the chinese air force made more
than 600 incursions into thailand's
aedes so far this year compared with
over 300 sorties last year other than
that since 2016 china has blew away a
third of taiwan's than 22 diplomatic
allies only 15 nations now mainly small
ones in the pacific and central america
recognize taiwan after kiribati became
the latest one to switch thais to
beijing in 2019
and china has brought imports of several
of taiwan's agricultural products while
taiwan's presence hyungwon has
repeatedly offered to hold direct talks
with the chinese authorities beijing
says taiwan's government must first
acknowledge it is part of china
something thai is unwilling to do
[Music]
the u.s china clash over taiwan has
re-emerged as one of the world's biggest
geopolitical risks according to some
defense analysts while the world's
powers have plenty of incentives to
avoid war china's rapid military rise
and increasing incursions into taiwan's
aeds have raised the risk of
miscalculation last week beijing urged
washington to abide by its agreements to
keep troops out of taiwan after an
american defense official confirmed that
some u.s military advisors have been
deployed in taiwan the confirmation
comes a day after the white house
announced a virtual meeting between
president joe biden and chinese
president xi jinping before the end of
the year
it remains to be seen whether both sides
can find middle grounds on various
issues including the one in the taiwan
screen
[Music]